Let's get into it,
let's get into it.
So,
do you wanna start with
your favorite game?
This is always the question, me and Sonja,
do we start low and go high?
Do we start high and go low?
What are you feeling?
What do you feel?
Do you wanna start with a game
you hate the most or love the most?
Best or worst?
Me?
Yeah.
This is the thing, cause best game
is something that you can
talk about for a long time.
Worst game is like, everyone always asks,
like, what's your least favorite movie?
What's your least
favorite game? It's like,
I don't know, I probably
forgot it cause it was so shit.
Oh that's true. Indifference-
I do have
Indifference is truly
the opposite of love.
Yeah, I do have some
that are kind of obvious,
and some that I think some
people will not agree with,
so we could, we could burn
the bridge immediately
if you want to.
Let's burn it.
Let's do that. Burn it down.
It's a little cold in
here, let's start a fire,
let's do it.
I mean the obvious ones are
stuff like, like Fallout 76,
cause that was just a shit show.
Yep.
And you have stuff like the
old ET game and Superman.
Sure.
Classics.
That's true.
But that's like, that's low hanging fruit.
So low.
I was going to say that Sonic
`06 would have been one...
Whoa.
Oh.
Because have either of you
ever played Sonic 2006?
No.
Is that the 3D one?
Was is that bad?
[Aaron] No, no.
It's, it's pretty bad.
Oh.
Why? Why?
Cause it's just, it well,
it's not my least favorite game now,
but it's... it just, it didn't work.
It was like, what have you done to Sonic?
It's like you took him outside,
gave him a coffee enema,
and then shot him.
(Aaron laughs)
Did you just feel like insulted?
And it was glitchy.
You'd go through the walls.
The gameplay just wasn't
good. The story was crap.
I know it was my least favorite
game for a long time until I
tweeted about it.
Okay.
And then, the Sonic team saw it.
I love that.
Love when that happens.
And then personally sent
me a physical edition of
(people laughing)
Sonic The Hedgehog: Jacksepticeye Edition.
Oh my God. They made you your own edition.
Yeah. And I,
they put my fake quote on it
that said "The world's greatest
video game of all time."
(Aaron laughs)
Now I have one of the shittiest games
of all time with my name on it.
And it even has like
pictures of me on the back.
Oh, they trolled you so hard.
It's like signed by the team.
Wow.
Wow, so funny.
I'm like,
You can't hate it that much now.
Can't do it.
This is how we get, then now
we know bribery works on you.
We know, we know your price.
Yeah.
A little Photoshop and a box cover.
I'm cheap.
That's what it takes.
If I ever hate you just,
send me a gift.